نتابع الدقائق الاخيره من تحليق طائره
ترامب في الاجواء قبل ان تحط وصلت يعني
الى ارض المطار تقريبا قبل ان تحط في هذه
اللحظات اذا طائره الرئيس ترامب تحط في
هذه الاثناء على مدرج مطار لاغوارديا في
نيويورك تمهيدا لجلسه محاكمته غدا طبعا
كنا علمنا بانه مسؤول بالمحكمه حسب وسائل
اعلام امريكيه قال ان المحاكمه من المقرر
يطهر ان تعقد الساعه السادسه مساء بتوقيت
جرينتش
اذا نشاهد هذه الطائره طائره ترامب وصلت
الى المطار تمهيدا لجلسه الغد جهاز الخدمه
السريه واداره شرطه نيويورك وضباط المحكمه
ينسقون الاجراءات الامنيه لظهور الترامب
غدا ترامب الذي قال نحن الان رسميا دوله
من العالم الثالث حيث لم يتعرض اي رئيس في
تاريخ بلدنا لمثل هذه الهجمات الشرسه
والمثيره للاشمئزاز على حد وصفه ولكنهم
يهاجمونني فقط لانني اقاتل من اجلكم واضح
انه دائما يعني يحاول ان يخاطب جمهوره
بشكل مباشر لما لذلك من تاثيرات على حملته
الانتخابيه المفترضه وهو يعني يريد المزيد
من الدعم لهذه الحمله طبعا هذه القضيه
ليست القضيه الوحيده التي واجهها ترامب
طبعا التحقيقات معه باكثر من تصرف تصرفات
ترامب في انتخابات عام 2020 وايضا احتفاظه
بوثائق سريه تحدثنا عنها منذ قليل